Axel met cette réunion ce sommet est
très symbolique pour réaffirmer le
soutien de l'Europe à l'Ukraine oui il
pensait donc un sommet européen dans un
pays en guerre pays qu'il n'appartient
pas à l'Union européenne c'est tout
simplement du jamais vu une
démonstration de force pour dire à la
Russie les 27 sont unis alors que le 24
février cela fera un an que la guerre a
commencé que les premiers bombardements
russes ont eu lieu sur sur l'ukraineur
les 27 chefs d'État de gouvernement ne
sont pas physiquement présents
aujourd'hui notamment pour des raisons
de sécurité mais représenté par trois
personnalités de l'Union européenne
notamment
Ursula vanderlayen la présidente de la
Commission européenne il y a aussi le
président du Conseil européen Charles
Michel et le chef de la diplomatie de
l'Union européenne l'espagnol Joseph
Borel un sommet qui fait suite à une
journée de travail hier à Kiev en
présence et vous les voyez ici d'une
quinzaine de commissaires européens qui
ont échangé avec les ministres
Ukrainiens donc là aussi avoir autant de
commissaires européens réunis c'était
une première cet historique et le
Conseil européen a quant à lui annoncé
le déblocage d'une aide militaire de 500
millions d'euros chiffres que vous avez
aperçu tout à l'heure dans le sujet de
Julien chedda mais les 500 millions
d'euros complètent déjà des milliards
qui ont été versés ou promis pour pour
l'Ukraine ce chiffre c'est 60 milliards
d'euros depuis le début du conflit et
aujourd'hui lors du sommet entre les
hauts représentants européens et le
pouvoir ukrainien avec le président
Zelinski il sera notamment question de
l'adhésion de l'Ukraine à l'Union
européenne mais justement le principal
problème n'est-il pas celui de la
corruption quid des contrôles donnés de
l'argent donné par l'Union européenne à
l'Ukraine oui vous avez tout à fait
raison de souligner ça si on fait un
petit rembobine en juin dernier la
Commission européenne recommande
l'octroi du statut de candidat ce qui a
pu d'ailleurs donner l'impression que
l'adhésion serait rapidement il ne
s'agissait entre guillemets que de
proposer que l'Ukraine rapidement être
candidate à une adhésion à l'Union
européenne mais il fallait et il faut
toujours pour cela que l'Ukraine s’attle
à une série de réformes législatives et
politiques ça passe notamment par la
lutte contre la corruption et ces
derniers jours comme par hasard diront
les esprits
sceptiques à ces derniers jours zenzky a
lancé une série une grande campagne anti
corruption et fort saluer par
Ursula vanderleyen dans son programme
actuel le format littéraire
international lui rappelle qu'il y a des
conditions sur la lutte contre la
corruption conditions qui permettent de
savoir quel sera le volume et la
rapidité de cette aide international
voilà donc cette corruption
effectivement est une partie essentielle
de ce que des relations entre l'Union
européenne et les bailleurs de fonds et
l'Ukraine qui est jusqu'à aujourd'hui la
plaque tournante d'un trafic d'armes
comment réagissent les Russes ce sommet
entre l'Union européenne et Kiev alors
ils ont pas en tout cas Vladimir Poutine
n'a pas tout à fait réagit frontalement
lui il a profité des de l'anniversaire
des 80 ans de la victoire soviétique
contre Stalingrad à hast Stalingrad
contre les Allemands pour dire vous
savez faire cette comparaison qu'il aime
bien avec la Seconde Guerre mondiale et
expliquer à propos vous avez ces chars
léopard les chats allemands qui seront
prêtés ou en tout cas donner plutôt
donné à l'Ukraine en expliquant on va de
nouveau voir des chars allemands avec
des croix sur alors il ne parle pas des
croix gammées directement enfin
l’allusion est quand même assez assez
franche assez forte et puis à côté de ça
il y a alors lui qui a été encore plus
frontal Sergueï labroff le ministre des
Affaires est étrangères de Vladimir
Poutine qui a expliqué Sergueï lavrof ce
qui se passe il a carrément lui nommé
celui-là vanderleans ce qui se passe
c'est que l'Union européenne veut la
chute de de la Russie et il a eu cette
ce mot inquiétant attention à la
Moldavie vous savez la Moldavie c'est ce
petit pays situé entre la Roumanie et
l'U attention à la Moldavie qui pourrait
être la prochaine Ukraine merci beaucoup
Axel mais pour votre analyse merci à
vous